[Music]
[Music]
so could could you please say your
full-name into the microphone Patricia
Williams lean it's my four lang but I
kept my maiden name in case you don't
Hank right so I just dropped his name
instead of changing the [ __ ] is either
is easy to dropped and change well
Patricia Williams leaned yes no middle
name thank you for being on the show
well thank you for having me what is
your name I am Joel Byers okay you never
told me your name and if you did I
forget as I'm Joel Byers I'm hosting the
hot breath podcast here so let's hop
into it where did you first perform
stand-up comedy and a place here in
Atlanta called the pub helvering I don't
know I was in my twenties I was out
thirty I think I was right
fifteen years about 13 years them but I
was in my early 30s when I started Wow
which is old as [ __ ] and I have no idea
and you automatically think oh I made
these people laugh I'm gonna be famous
in two weeks it doesn't work like that
mm-hm you don't know what the [ __ ] you
doing the first time you go onstage all
I did was just cussed out this white
girl it made it it was really funny I
was joining her you know roasting
roasting her and people were like I'm a
comedian I [ __ ] the [ __ ] did you do any
perform anything as a kid at all uh-uh
and I was being a mama in in jail as a
kid you did some like at the growing up
at the bootleg house did you entertain
some there yeah it was called dancing
for drunk people okay so if I was gonna
use that list and I would have been a
stripper stripper
[Laughter]
so I didn't want to use that list and
that's why I'll never dance I hate
[ __ ] dancing I'll go right back to
the bootleg house I was like I hate this
[ __ ] so I grew up doing it for drunk
people and nasty-looking old me is I pop
that ass baby
pop that ass baby and I don't even sound
right this no but you were a baby when
it was happening I wasn't well I was
about eight yeah and I could pop my ass
too so they were hecklers back then as
well no it was [ __ ] they wanted to [ __ ]
you back there yeah I just wanted to rub
on your undeveloped chest
wow you can appreciate their honesty
that's why every hood got a big alley
man to get you ready for the real world
I'm quite sure you didn't have a
dingaling man you white David oh richard
engel a man any girl [ __ ] about a Dingle
main man into ghetto
he kept the key isn't in line man white
kids chasing ice cream truck black kids
run away from the data line man least
there was a neighborhood watch my kid I
said back there kids and really get
kidnapped like they do now I was like
where where'd the [ __ ] happened to the
good old Dingle a man the person who
picked you up
rub on your booty get your files and
bring you back home no more digging we
may they come child molesters me
everything so PC now yeah yeah one PC
when I was giving birth day 14 oh wow
well at least you didn't you grew up and
got your chops early you could say cuz
yeah they was given to you you didn't
have a choice what I've noticed
interviewing a lot of comics from
Atlanta is we all have a boo story
getting booed on stage what's yours I
had a duty try me once I was doing like
open mic over in the new orleans-style
restaurant over for Peachtree Copeland's
so they used to do comedy there at night
and it was this dude that was booming
appraiser to be paid nobody really
listened to comedy but he was booming
behind a wall and he had a skull cap on
and I lit his ass up
so I mean I've never been I don't think
I've been booed where I had to just lead
a stage I always fought back so what was
what's the story about you having nerf
balls thrown at you oh that's oh my god
I was I was with my friend double D you
know double D know that we were coming
from Atlanta so he signed me up because
I have been doing I've been doing open
mic for about two three months so we
over get grill from he was refused to be
on v-103 at the time so we go to his
room and if the people don't like you
they throw these nerf balls at you I
didn't know that so as the people come
into the comedy spot they get a payday
ticket money they get they give them as
many nerf balls as they want so double D
sign me up and I looked at eyes like
come Tuesday me pair like [ __ ] baby
pal I didn't mean all right [ __ ] do
you sign me up he's like yeah you gotta
start going on stage more so I get up
there I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
doing nervous because I've never really
been in front of a real comedy crowd and
I'm not doing well and so this young
dude look nice dress black gentleman hit
me in my forehead with a [ __ ] nut
ball and I'm from the hood I'm a batter
[ __ ] you ain't [ __ ] hitting me and I
said [ __ ] teaches him I have never
[ __ ] ball I said hit me again [ __ ]
imma jump out this stage and I'm gonna
smash your [ __ ] ass with that
turtleneck on hey I picked that ball up
and I hit this sumbitch in the chest in
the crowd just went rock that was my
first standing ovation running Jordan
big ass in the corner Holland screaming
Lee that muscle give me that anyone no
regular it was Nerf ball that kind of
bounce on the ground that [ __ ]
hit me and put a dent in my forehead and
I got a big phony
ever [ __ ] Abreu I had a flashback of my
baby daddy beat me I said [ __ ] hit me
with another ball and it's gonna be on a
day and then I jumped up and said [ __ ]
that [ __ ] y'all is Rob
why I wanted to rob somebody at a comedy
show
I don't know cuz I just kind of like
come out of the streets you don't
[ __ ] put your hands on me dude I work
too hard to keep your [ __ ] hands
on me I put his hand on me I tried oh my
god I said y'all is robbing in the crowd
he was so scared of me he had on the big
tournament I said hit me with another
ball [ __ ] I choke your ass out with
that goddamn turtleneck on puss-ass
while I was calling him everything you
know I was mad I was really mad that was
my that's my boo story I went home and
you know like I'm I was going through
some lady problems my peer was almost
Cuba French and you're [ __ ] the one
when they'd stop [ __ ] psycho I was
going crowd right at home on from me you
hit a [ __ ] and hair with a little nerve
ball and my hormones messing up - I went
I couldn't believe it but we I used to
have it on video it's the funny [ __ ] my
house cuz I told my hood I took at home
and my cheese they was on the floor it's
the funniest [ __ ] I need to find out
that VCR tape that would go viral now it
probably would get smacked in the face
with a Nerf ball dude I couldn't believe
it
I couldn't have fun every ball was that
before you started doing your true
stories and kind of joke I don't suck
dick I got vertigo well you started
comedy before you even knew what it was
your caseworker was like your stories
are hilarious yeah get on stage and do
stand-up but she didn't really say she
said you should tell these stories on so
I'm not telling my business it took a
lot as a comic to open up because you
open up like that you allowing people to
you into your life into your secrets
that you always had and never really
told nobody but I found it I find it to
be a way for me to heal when I when I
can
Oh Polly tell you and I'm not
embarrassed anymore that I had two kids
by a married man at 14 then that that
that allowed me to hear healed and also
that allowed me to not let that
situation have control on me
comedy help me get over a lot of this
[ __ ] well I've heard you say you know
you can only talk about what you have
forgiven yes and that doesn't have
control of you anymore
exactly but do you mean you mean you
really have every reason to you know be
ain't be angry and you look at it I can
look at it and say oh well society led
me down but you know I I started to tell
myself you know you're only gonna get
out of life what you put into life and I
got there I got that saying from get up
and get out and get something from our
case was like don't nobody stop feeling
sorry for you nobody had never told me
that
they don't tell you that in the ghetto
there was all these things - oh you
can't get up out to get oh yes you can
you know what's crazy I would just visit
my sister and she living the way we used
to live his kids and I called my husband
I said you know what I realize that they
get the ghetto the hood is like the
desert don't nothin grow so nothing grow
what the [ __ ] grow in the desert dust
thank you and that's what the [ __ ]
look like dusty I'm like come take your
pistol with me to go see my sister in
the head jeez I mean honestly I got on a
ring that I don't know stolen and I love
my relatives but I'm like I'm not going
over there by myself and oh hell no God
I'm a convicted felon so she put off 45
her pocketbook and I wouldn't go tell my
sister hey and I love oh how are you
able to forgive I mean just one example
that comes to my mind is like your dad
the first time you meet him you're 11 he
beats you thinking you're my sister and
then you don't meet him again till the
late 20s but then you take care of them
yes I can see that yes I did I mean how
did I mean there's there's no role model
even suggesting that to be an option how
do you forgive cuz I don't hold grudges
see when you hold grudges
and when you hate it controls you like
people how do you talk to your baby
daddy he beats you he shot you he did
all these things you because I don't
know how to hold a grudge
I don't know how to hate I know how not
to [ __ ] with you but I don't know how to
hate I mean hate is a strong is a strong
word for you to say I hate you so every
time you go see that person to think
about that person that person brain pain
to you so why am I gonna hate you I
don't want you that I don't want you to
bring pain to me every time I think
about you
you know so I just I don't I don't hold
a grudge I just I look at life like this
if it's bigger than me then I give it to
my god
and I don't have control over what
people done to me I can only control
what I can control what's in front of me
now I can't go back and say hey why
y'all do all this [ __ ] to me for what
what I'm gonna be sitting around crying
over that [ __ ] [ __ ] if it do is not
gonna allow me to grow I'm happy I'm
smiling you're looking at a [ __ ] you've
been [ __ ] hit be shot molested
everything and I smile every day and
don't none of the [ __ ] cross my
mind with a negative vibe I'm writing a
book I'm gonna do some fucked-up [ __ ] to
us and I'm like hold on y'all that's
still my [ __ ] mama because I don't
hate my mama see you got a you gotta
realize a lot of this [ __ ] is a lot of
holidays she is a cycle that's what I
had to realize it's a cycle what you
know you pass down to your kids if you
don't learn [ __ ] then all you can pass
down to your kids is what you know so
that's what happened my mom and my is
from generation to generation nobody
learnt [ __ ] so they kept passing down
[ __ ] but one day I was like y'all ain't
this [ __ ] ain't bout to suck my kids up
so I started to surround myself around
better people I'm sorry I needed
somebody who say who I could say what
they were right here me so I mean that's
why I'm not angry I'm happy I forgiving
my baby daddy for you know for beating
on me for shoe me for [ __ ] really
molested me had two kids by Mary man in
15 I forgive me my momma i forgiving my
daddy i forgiving a lot of people they
don't even know it I'm happy
I'm doing good the jury
second-grade teacher have any influence
a big influence miss truth she had a big
influence I think she put the hustling
me she made me believe even when I was
doing time in jail and I was at my Lords
lie always quoted what she said miss
true said Patricia you could be anything
in the world you want to be all you got
to do is believe have a dream and I tell
my husband today I say you I said y'all
think I'm spontaneous but I didn't I was
like you just jump up and do [ __ ] you
know I've been dreaming about this [ __ ]
I've been feeling it I've been putting
it in the universe I believe everything
if I want something and my dad was like
I tell him how i'ma get that he was like
yeah he look up and I get him he think
I'm playing
that's just how I work I believe I mean
that lady told me that [ __ ] in the
bathroom when I was like second third
grade and she just died last year
and I still quote her and I still think
her to this day she was definitely a
mother figure
yes and all my hair she brushed my teeth
she gave me clean clothes means she let
me know that when I go home [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up but things can get better and
you've done the same for a lot of kids
too oh yeah I was just with my cousin my
cousin we just walked it up I told her I
said I said putting you in the book
because my cousin I go over my house I
don't know I probably probably 16 at the
time with two kids and my cousin is
being raised in a situation I was in so
I tell my tell say why don't you let boo
come live with me and she's like okay
cuz she already had like eight church
and everybody having babies so boo come
live with me and at this time I'm Vee
I'm a good I'm a I'm a big-time drug
dealer not the kingpin tight but I'm
making good money to be 16 so I teach my
niece how to do sell drugs we couldn't
we do everything together after I break
off from the mind you I'm sixteen so my
cousin is four years y'all gonna me so
instead ten four years yes yeah she's 12
goddamn I'm taping it alone they're so
close so she's 12 years old and she's
selling drunk with me
she's just selling drugs with me and so
she get about 14 and she'd take a dope
case for me
determinants get me so she go to
juvenile and she get pregnant and she go
to juvenile and she do the time for me
and I told her today I said put you in a
book I just want to tell you I'm sorry I
[ __ ] up your life and she told me she
said [ __ ] you saved me she said cuz I
could be like your sister
I could be like my sister yeah I took a
dope charge from you but you taught me a
lot of [ __ ] about the youth and I almost
teared up cuz I to me I [ __ ] her life
up she went to jail for two years she
gave birth to her first child in jail
she got pregnant she was all the [ __ ]
she was just we were just doing this
cycle you know you know high school
dropout we both dropped out she end up
getting her GED later on too and she
only taught shopping and Nicator and I
was like I [ __ ] your life up and she's
like no you didn't you saved me I said
yeah I saved you from one thing but I
put you and I put you in some dangerous
situation she's like what you family
she said you taught me a lot even though
you won't you won't admit it and I think
about that all the time that's what
that's what [ __ ] me up about the whole
drug dealing because I brought so many
other kids that I was trying to help but
I was a kid myself I'm not making
excuses for me but I [ __ ] up their
life I got another niece who I left she
still selling drugs I don't think she's
doing it to this day but I got another
niece then when we used to [ __ ] do
ugly legal [ __ ] I got her locked up and
then they took charges with me but you
know she's good she's working she got a
good job she's in Texas now but I've
asked her mouth I tell him I said I
[ __ ] your life up
I introduce y'all to [ __ ] y'all
shouldn't be introduced to but I was
like rabbit you saved us because they
mama was on drugs and she and they look
at him being saved but I looked at I
couldn't did a better job but again I
was only 16 but you also help kids not
only in like the drug realm but didn't
you also run a concession stand at one
time yeah hired kids to work that city
yeah because I lived in Riverdale so how
are those kids was just you know they
didn't I'd never work with a group of
dumbass people in my life I'm being I
cannot believe today's youth dumbest
four kids can't even goddamn count
changement without the rest
Oh [ __ ] 52 sick counts from 52
and I own up to $1 they didn't know [ __ ]
so I taught them a lot a lot of them you
know they went on the date that most of
them went on to college a lot of them
went on to do good things in life most
of them got good jobs but I mean a lot
of the parents was you know with you and
interceding most of them singing parents
household the one parent is working
there so it's kind of hard to raise a
kid so lot of them like hung around me
cuz I'm a state I was a stay-at-home mom
I just went to the dorm and [ __ ] and so
but talking to him there was some there
was some stupid [ __ ] but I've
not kept it real with them and that's
what they like about me I tell them
names like they would go right now say
well if you're just gonna give somebody
your [ __ ] then what do you have I mean
you you don't let somebody you're gonna
go and have sex with somebody and then
they disrespect you and that's what they
had no value they just thought oh
everybody having sex I supposed to ever
say whoever is [ __ ] get you aids
what happen when you get a baby [ __ ]
you cannot stick a baby back up your
[ __ ] baby it's not a tampon okay when
is out is out and I just told [ __ ] like
that I was like you know stand up for
yourself don't ever let nobody walk off
y'all never seen a group of weak-minded
[ __ ] in my life cuz I mean I
guess cuz I raised myself and like they
weren't they were bow down to my
daughter cuz my daughter my daughter was
like my daughter [ __ ] a push oh she
she like to push people over and I saw
nice look yeah I don't have to bow down
to my daughter cuz y'all work for me cuz
this [ __ ] out don't let her talk to
y'all and you let me cuss yeah but don't
let my daughter cuss you out okay so
just a lot of it and they still think me
to this that is like I learn a lot from
you but I just kept it real with them
you know like when I'm having a kid he's
a preacher nays name is Antonio and
Antonio was uh he was in line to be
valedictorian Riverdale high which is
not a big deal cuz you deal with all
black kids on 3 1 Omega valedictory so
we say no and and tonio thought he was
better than all the other kids and I
told her and Tony you gots Antonio you
know you want to have you know
in the air and you don't want to hang
out with the smart kids what you think
it's smart I said in the dumb kids you
don't want to be bothering them I said
when you get out in the real world you
got to deal with all kind of people I
mean from Oprah Winfrey lever down to a
[ __ ] crack hey you got to know
how to talk to all people so if you
don't know how if you only know how to
talk to one group of people then your
life is limited [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] on me all the time
I'm gonna talk to Obama
I can talk to Obama and I've talked to a
cranky at my Craig answers and I ain't
got to change who I am I said but you I
said you need to find out who you are
you pretending to be something that you
not I said so all you I said don't don't
don't [ __ ] close people out because
you feel like they can't use them on
nice ass words you use they don't mean
[ __ ] when your [ __ ] when your character
it's it's [ __ ] up when the person you
really are inside it's [ __ ] up I said
won't you treat everybody to say whether
they dumb smug black white green with
one eye and they [ __ ] here
treat everybody the same and I talked to
him a couple of months ago he said
that's one thing I learned from you we
we are the same and we ought to say I
mean I'm different fatter than you you
white I'm black you probably got a
college degree and I probably know how
to cook cocaine that's why they call you
Miss pizzle I hated that was a for Snoop
Dogg doing the the drizzles and all that
I don't know what them kids got there
for me they caught my son now he calls
me mr. pills oh and he called me juicy
oh I hate that you don't call your
[ __ ] mama juicy that's nasty
not to him what's up juice I said don't
call me juice a [ __ ] sorry we're
closing yeah so we go I always look like
a cougar with him and I had the temper
I'm not [ __ ] him this is my son
stop putting this balmy dummies [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] people who can go more than
twice I'm sorry child get there we're
good at all I love your honesty and your
you're a natural-born hustler I mean
even I mean it's in your genes your mom
would take the family around to
different churches
yeah so they would pay the bills in the
food yeah it started before that yes
starting with grenaded bootleg house
mm-hmm
as far as I can remember my granddaddy
sold looker so I mean the hustler came
from there you know like I'm quite sure
you heard the story hi hey there's still
a lot of people pocket and my mom will
pay me $5 per person that's a lot of
money for an eight-year-old to go play
pac-man and so I've never seen nobody
with no job literally I was talking to
my cousin that's - do you know that
nobody has a job in our family nobody
has a career my cousin on at I shot my
brother is a fake-ass mechanic he he fix
people cause and change his phone number
[Laughter]
and everybody's just living off the
system I got longer there's a mechanic
and I told my cousin I was like
literally nobody has a career other than
I have a comedy career she got a tie
shop and my brother
my brothers are fake hands mechanic and
I'm looking at like my dick my
granddaddy keys he ain't key but I'm
looking at all of them the one that's
not in jail nobody really has a career
well you do I have a career yes cuz I
don't [ __ ] with them she's doing really
well so she I mean she has something
going on but it's just these three
people that I can think of those tough
experiences have certainly paid off I
mean by 15 you have two kids you've been
shot twice
you're not only a crack dealer you're
like the plug on the block do you
running it you're making like 10 grand a
week doing this yeah I made a lot of
money sometimes I'm a day yeah so like
how how was that hustle carried over
into comedy game ah that's a good
question I used the same I use the same
tactics like you got to get up you got
when everybody else is sleeping you got
to be putting your [ __ ] product
together which is jokes Nestor Bret
and we're like literally if I come home
from an open Michael I come home I come
from a show I literally get out my
laptop and if I've been working on
anything I go right to work on it I
don't have a problem with going open mic
you know some people think I ain't got
time for the open mic sheet I don't have
a problem if I fly into a state you're
on if I see you got an open mind and I'm
your head in line I waste a closed hey
let me come close I down for money just
cuz I want to work on [ __ ] it's the same
hustle you know the early bird catches
the worm I wait I still wake up at I
mean I go to the gym a lot now so I
literally get up at 3 o'clock and go to
the gym and then I [ __ ] coming to my
hotel room I get making made and I work
on my laptop
were there any bad habits you had to
break no I never did drugs never smoked
eating is my [ __ ] bad habit can't you
see it all in my face and ass from the
hustle side of it were there any things
that didn't carry over you had to kind
of get away from yea jail jail jail for
being too funny just you know like
working alone and when when you hustling
like that everything comes fast and when
you earning your money the right way
everything comes slow so that's what
that's what the Shocker right there
because my husband straight out of the
military I always had a job and I'm like
he was like you need to quit selling
drugs and [ __ ] you don't get a job
and I'm like [ __ ] what they do that is
[Laughter]
over $2,000 pocketbook what would I do
that kind of [ __ ] but he kill so I was
saying that's the bad habit you don't
always want to find a hustle so that's
why I started doing the dolmen that's
why I started doing other [ __ ] and and
you know I never really just had a
really a job it's all we had to be for
myself even when I worked that journal
mode I was like this [ __ ] too slow for
me my was like oh these $22.00 I'll [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
you put that [ __ ] all in the back of
that car I'm gonna go find something on
my own to do and he couldn't get it he
couldn't get it I said because I like to
be in control
hmm I like to be in control I like to
say this is what
gonna didn't I don't want to do that
when you had a job you got a clock in
and do the same [ __ ] over and over again
I hate doing the same she don't know
again the great part about being a
comedian at least you can change your
outfit on the back of your sit and go to
the front of you'll say oh you can start
in the middle what a job you like
building the cars and saying [ __ ]
over and over again just watching people
get old I'm not a [ __ ] old people
watching I'm like living I like doing
[ __ ] but my husband y'all mind doing it
be that reliability of your husband has
certainly been the turning point in
their life [ __ ] yeah he's a foundation
when I was going out doing open mics it
probably a plane ticket so I had to go
to Missouri and do open my what the [ __ ]
you don't get it you understand this
[ __ ] is real but he would complain but
he would do it he was doing I mean
honestly he's been the foundation of my
career I always call him I hate him
because he don't think I'm funny and he
never really thought I was funny he's
like telling a [ __ ] chicken
coop jokes a lot of things but in the
beginning when he had to take his credit
card out and you know [ __ ] fly me in
the book to to do an open mind trying to
showcase for a gig or I'm driving
somewhere and only making $50 but don't
want to tell him why making no damn
money but he didn't understand that side
of you know all he knows I punch in I
make a certain amount of money it's
always gonna be there
we're comedy you don't get the same
amount of money in the beginning I mean
never you really get to say my money
everybody offer you what they think you
were and some in the beginning was 15
out how the hell you're gonna try to
hide real graffiti at all oh that's $50
[ __ ] to $50 it's stage time and he can
understand how valuable the stage time
was versus the money like and literally
if I do a TV interview they're gonna pay
you I said shut the [ __ ] up I don't get
paid for in a TV interview that's what
he don't understand
yeah I just drove nine hours to Kokomo
Indiana for $100 so oh yeah Ronnie yeah
yeah but your your husband was at least
a comedy fan because you guys
didn't meet at a comedy show there's
comedy karaoke it was coming to karaoke
yeah we went to go see Bruce Bruce
lip-synching lip-sync got a backstage
no okay oh yeah that was backstage what
you know about backstage backstage oh
it's a laundromat now I'm out here I'm
on the hustle it was it was like a
little hot spot I don't want to say it
was like a Friday night and Bruce Bruce
was hosting and they had comedians and
they had lip-syncing and boy we went
down at night and he just I knew his
brother already and he said across the
table I was like hey fat boy you want
split some wings and so we started
talking and he didn't know that I had an
heir hiring baby daddy sign out so I
needed a baby daddy and I was like oh he
got a big teaching gene but not only his
reliability but with his job having the
reliable job at GM it took him up to
Indianapolis where really my career took
a turn a huge pivot yes white people it
was it was not the scenery here that I
was used to in Atlanta and I tell you
moving the Indianapolis probably and I
know moving in and Napoli saved my
career cuz god no I probably be
somewhere going in circles it was there
when I went to the comedy club you know
one of the managers like you really got
some good I was telling about my life
but not on stage he's like you should
say they don't stay not like this [ __ ]
ain't funny he's like yes it is funny
and so we were just talking and and by
being at Morty's Dade County
they helped me started to put my set
together you know my friend Avery
diligent who works there still there and
he started to help me put my scent
together to - for me to have something
to talk about other than brooches and
you know [ __ ] they you hear a lot of
black comics talk about so it allowed it
opened my eyes moving Indianapolis
really open my I had no I no idea that
was a joke consist of opening middle and
ending
a premise so regulate of you if you ever
go to a black Club you see a lot of
black coming on again as a premise a
funny-ass preemies like oh that joke is
funny no [ __ ] that's just a
premise yeah it's a good idea good start
good start but it's Neptunia yeah my
girlfriend got hit by a car Oh [ __ ]
pojat what a joke why your girl forgot
about a car why your girlfriend a
poacher what happened after your
girlfriend they don't a lot of them no
go to so and s would come that's what I
learned from being in Indianapolis the
craft the craft of it yeah you know and
and just fleeing myself on stage just
you know not being ashamed of what I
went through that's when I really
started talking about who I was and I
and I thought people who couldn't relate
but I was wrong it don't matter where
you come from who you are is something
in my scent that you can relate to if it
didn't happen to you
you know him mother [ __ ] who had a
baby yawn you know somebody who's on
welfare you know somebody who did this
you know somebody who did that
I hope you [ __ ] adjust a mammogram
joke everybody got titties all the women
got titties right I don't give you two
days ago you're moving yeah it is right
so that's how I try to write you know I
and I don't go out to get a certain
group of people I just tell you about me
I probably can't get you as a fan and
personally I don't give a [ __ ] you know
what can I do I can't say shake you up
in there I want you to think I'm funny
person I don't give a [ __ ] I'm a
grown-ass woman I just got to do what I
do and keep it moving
everybody I had to learn that
everybody's not gonna like you as a
comedian I wanted everybody to like me
but I started thinking with [ __ ] my own
real daddy didn't like me so why am i
chasing these [ __ ] then I don't
know I didn't know my real dad not in
chases ass so I was like [ __ ] it I don't
care if you like me and that shows the
resilience of your character and that
you're pretty much raised to almost be
scared of white people yeah I was very
scared of him well my mama said she sees
to say [ __ ] like all white people is
better than you don't ever look him in
the eye day the devil you know of course
you know black people take out a devil I
don't think you to devil but that's how
I was raised don't ever look at me
this is like they're better than me so
when I moved to Indianapolis and I met a
mainstream club I'm no longer head
uptown I'm in a place where I might be
the only [ __ ] black person in the
club beside one of the other owners and
I look up and and it would just did I
would come out of stainable oh my god
you so fun and I would look away because
I would talk to look away right and did
will make me nervous
and here's not all you so fun I said I
said get your [ __ ] hand on me for I
choked the [ __ ] out of you this is what
I would say to myself because I was
nervous I mean I had never really had
any interaction with white people other
than going to jail and it wasn't y'all
thought I went to jail or [ __ ] commit
a crime but when you in jail is you know
honestly the population is mostly black
people so I had never really interact
with them auntie I moved to Indianapolis
and you also made fun of comics doing
the white rooms you'd say oh you're
going and getting that white money well
that's what we used to say yeah like
people like drew who never was on the up
side town outside uptown side so we were
like drew over that getting that white
money [ __ ] him because that's all I knew
you know those are the people that I
knew but when I when I started to
realize what a real comedy wasn't when I
got to Indianapolis and when I got over
my whole fear when I was talking I was
like she you know if you write if you
write material if you write good
material you get all types of people
that like you from all no matter what
color they are so I stopped I never
tried to chase white people I never
tried to chase black people
I just wanted to be funny but just so
half of my my my comedy I got a lot a
lot more white fans and I do black fans
now because of what I do and I don't do
like a lot of the black show they don't
call me for it I'm just as funny as
anybody else but right now I don't get
called for that kind of stuff but I mean
I got a few but not as many as I do
Caucasian fan I don't know how did she
happen this is the crazy she didn't it
were to me one of the craziest things to
me is just the segregation of comedy
very I think with with the black comics
I think a lot of them like me you know
they think why people are not gonna get
it you know and you got on me a lot of
lingo we use like the way young people
talk today I have no [ __ ] idea what
they say I'm like what are you trying to
say
just beat [ __ ] Ebonics or correcting
what is this slang sheet I don't get it
so if you if you wouldn't if you are
black comedian and you using [ __ ] that
people ain't used to hearing every day
they're not gonna get your joke you know
I mean all you do it yo you watching
something that everybody's not watching
okay everybody watched a game of throne
right but don't everybody watch the Real
Housewives of Atlanta I'm black if you
own stage talking about the Real
Housewife of Allah I don't know the [ __ ]
you're talking about
because I don't watch The Real
Housewives of Atlanta that's what I'm
saying the Ganga throw it way more
people of all races watch Housewives of
Atlanta only certain that's a small
circle so I think with black comics we
get we get to thinking what then they're
never gonna get who we are but that's
not true if you're making your [ __ ] if
you making a [ __ ] big enough what's word
I'm looking for you know the [ __ ]
rental McKay Universal yes universal
enough to talk about something everybody
might be familiar with Michael Jackson
is universal right
[ __ ] uh future just only a
certain amount people know who the [ __ ]
daddy you go all around the world and
talk about Michael Jackson but you can't
go all around the room talk about a
month on your future cuz it don't work
like that so that's how comedy is where
you know if you talking about rap to me
I'm gonna [ __ ] you Tom I don't listen
around me unless the phone like ti2 pop
[ __ ] LL Cool J when they had
something to say muffles ain't got [ __ ]
[ __ ] your gold chain [ __ ] your car you
were in it for this video and [ __ ] your
hos it's paying off though on Last Comic
Standing you know you were one of the
few comics that got a like a feature
where they interview your family and
things
what was the qualification for that did
you they all use that afterwards there
was this all part of the deal uh once I
got once I got a acepted on the show and
they just called me up one day and
saying Tammy was unique about your
family I said we all fit well we don't
have diabetes
Lisa keys don't read
and they just said we would like to come
out to your house and do a you know to
meet your family and stuff so I said
okay come on out my kids want to be on
TV yeah so my daughter came up from
Atlanta and my they came out and it was
hilarious
did you see it did you see they watch my
daughter was so [ __ ] funny on that
she's funny anyway I try to get her to
do it but Mike she won't she's scared
her she's 17 and her whole dream is
going to Ivy League school to be the
first child her mom and dad had that has
a college degree so whole thing is about
whooping all the other kids and say oh I
told y'all I was better than y'all yeah
yeah and she's very she's very political
she liked to watch a lot of CNN I
accidently that she's always talking
about what's going on in the country and
so I told us that you gotta watch that
watching so much CNN because if you keep
watching someone's CNN it's gonna make
you it's gonna make you one man it like
people who watch Fox yeah yeah so she
was like I saw X I said are you racist
she said no I'm not racist but I'm she
said I'm not racist but um I'm
race-conscious so I said well what the
[ __ ] is race-conscious
she said she said I know what white
people think of black people I said what
do white people think of us she said I
think we all are lazy and unemployed so
I said well Gary honor you are lazy and
you unemployed I show you exactly why
people think you are she got so mad I
said but you black and you say this what
they think about you right
she was [ __ ] she was living she was so
mad at me I said well if you think
that's a way somebody think about a race
of people your race of people what
didn't want you won't you prove them
wrong why don't you prove Raza but you
are lazy and you are unemployed your
lasers [ __ ] I try to get your job you
said no because technically I was
responsible for you to you was 18 which
is [ __ ] genius
ya can outsmart Missy yeah she is
she's just something else so she got so
mad I was like you are lazy and you
[ __ ] are unemployed so you exactly
what you think white people think you
are well they have a mom that works
extremely hard yeah it's starting to pay
off
I'm so happy with how your career is
going right now
just seeing the positive feedback you've
got on Last Comic Standing all the
judges loved it the audience loved it
there seemed to be a moment between you
and Roseanne like do you guys have a
history together
yeah you saw I did a show called real
funny his mom man Roseanne took me out
to Vegas and open for a couple of shows
so yeah I do kind of have a history rose
and I like Rose ain't always pretty one
day did I get a sitcom and it's like I'm
there I'm the like Roseanne but a little
bit more easier so I prayed it they
happen one day what would you call the
sitcom
these pants show I'm gonna need to work
in dis muhfucka geek council is that one
of those kind of like how you dreamed
from Miss truth-telling you can dream
and make it happen is this one of those
yeah things are dreaming that yet gonna
make happen
I've always yeah I've always dreamed it
I was having my own sitcom one day I
always dreamed that I was be selling out
of theatres one day my whole dream is to
come up through the floor stop you need
to see my big ants crawling up viral
well before the sitcom even comes out
you have a book coming out which you
being an eighth grade dropout now
releasing a book I didn't write the book
people I have a guy have a writer okay
I write Oh goddamn book I told the story
but I have a book coming out through
HarperCollins they purchased it last
year which I'm really excited about
because I mean cuz you know I do a lot
of Park has a lot of stories that I
cannot tell on stage there's just not it
doesn't fit the stage and you know in
but people really get to get to know who
I am when I went through and the book
start with saying have an open mind
before you want a judge cuz I did some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in my life and I laid all
lot in this book I mean I went through
some difficult times and you know I put
drunks and my kids drawers
I made some major mistakes oh I tell
people I say well you can admit that you
was a horrible mom in the beginning I
was a [ __ ] horrible mom yes I was 16
I was fifteen with two kids but that's
no excuse some of this [ __ ] I don't even
know if I knew better I wish I had known
better like selling drugs in front of
her school had an excuse my biggest
excuse was I was here I was actually
there before the no school drug signs
went up so when that's when the signs
went up I was already grandfathered in
yeah so technically you can't [ __ ] with
nobody who was there before you
[Laughter]
technically I was grandfather tell the
judge that oh yeah oh yeah I get more
time
[ __ ] you chop my school zones no selling
drugs in schools I was here before you
thought of this stupid [ __ ] and putting
them little babies on that [ __ ] I'm
talking about judge you had your way
around the law was there any sort of
like backdoor deals you were able to
work out with like judge or something
with your poll um I just had a good
lawyer oh did he shines he's still here
the landlord
and ones Gucci man he was my [ __ ]
lawyer first
[Laughter]
I met him we had just got became a
lawyer used to be a police outside yeah
used to be a police officer
and I met did it show you he was just
him no secretary smaller office but had
a good reputation with getting drug
dealers boner this is back when when you
first went to jail for drugs on Atlanta
back in the early 90s they didn't really
know the [ __ ] whole thing of it you
know how crazy it was so you could just
get a bellend right out the back when I
got locked up you didn't get a boner
right off the Bagdad changing like two
years later so I met Dennis shot to
another drug dealer we got out
I tell goodish all the time said [ __ ] I
gave you a career I hooked you up in the
who yet I took you to every drug dealer
every friend I had they got arrested I
said called any shot and I tell him that
all the time I said I talked to him
about six months ago yeah and he thanks
you you still call me rabbi said my name
is no [ __ ] rabbit okay I'm calling me
rabbit so he's like I gave your answer
career that's why you so popular in
Atlanta that's why all the drug dealers
and murderers knowing because of you uh
yeah the old school and the name just
kept traveling when you do a good job
your name travel is he in the book like
is that one of those he was young he had
hair look like a beautiful Superman
computer but I think did is had um fell
out he's older now
what was I seventeen when I first got
arrested so didn't Dennis had to be cuz
his kids was baby they they they grown
and married now Wow yeah that's how long
I've been knowing I mean these stories
in the book are some of them ones you
tried onstage but they weren't funny so
you have to save them for the book no
they just never stayed no there's not
stage material I mean there's only so
much you can put on stage that people
take be like god damn like sometime I
perform it and people people want to cry
I would love to know since your you have
all these great stories some of them are
worthy of stage I know you've said you
learned how to tell stories from Bill
Cosby yes Richard Pryor
so could you can maybe give a little
inside baseball in that process well I
have a next-door neighbor when I
referred there when I first started
doing comedy and he was like your voice
is raspy like mom Mabel and I had never
heard of MAME because I was not a comedy
person and I was sitting on my back
porch when I first started doing home
for Mikey just tell the story to my
next-door neighbor was a big comedy
person and um and I would tell he's like
you got stories like Richard Pryor and I
had heard Richard Pryor name first like
do my caseworkers she was like you know
RIT you funny like Richard Pryor oh your
stories are like Richard Pryor so my
neighbor kept saying it and I had
already googled him so I said well are
you
to tell a [ __ ] story but I really
didn't know how to put it together so
when I moved out to Indianapolis I mean
I started looking at Bill Cosby but I
couldn't get it I would see these
stories of how he was looping around and
bringing them back
how the [ __ ] did he do that but once I
got the Indianapolis around people who
kind of was familiar with that type of
comedy then I started to learn how to
just tell story I'm still learning I'm
no way as good as they are but neither
one on my wish you know Bill Cosby so
put you in when Bill Cosby says sorry
for all the [ __ ] he's going through
right but uh when he tell a story it's
almost like you read their wedding and
that's what I want people to get I want
you to is no matter what race you are I
want you to be in that looker house and
see how [ __ ] up this situation is and
still laugh at it so can you do that
just on a minor adjustments like just
use a joke example from Last Comic
Standing how you talk about how you're
running away from somebody shooting at
you and the old old version of the joke
is you saying it was 20 years ago when
they built strong fences but on Last
Comic Standing you say you ran through
the fence
does that give a more visual cue to the
audience is that why you change it
jumping over the fence is the original
version yes
when I did it for Comedy Central I
changed it to running through the fence
so it was a little bit more funnier you
know jokes is even though it's how truth
I am you still have to tweak it a little
bit and when I did it no way it got a
bigger laugh because people can actually
see your big ass ain't jumping on no
fence you might have ran through a fence
so you can see my began to run into a
fence in there so just for visual
matters yeah so that's that's how jokes
work you know you still keep the truth
down but you still have to torque it a
little bit twerk it
yeah twerk you know tweak it is a tweak
it old twerk is the the booty shake and
dance oh you can get to too if that's
what you like so tweak you that's how
you have a baseline story and then
you'll just embellish certain if I need
to yeah because I'm living like my
stories of fucked-up stories so it's
gonna make you cringe and I could tell
the peep
like we need who and they holding back
okay I can give you a bell in the sample
okay I got shot in the head by my baby
daddy right so for years I couldn't
never get people to laugh at that joke
and I was like this is funny to me
everything is funny to me and my meds
like it's not funny for dude to shoot a
woman in the back of the head I see
something there it's funny so I kept
playing around with it so one day I said
you know my kid's father saw I've been
through a lot in my life my kid's father
shot me in the back of the Amelia I like
what the [ __ ] I said but don't worry it
was not his fault it was my fault cuz I
don't slow blood dig he shot in the back
of my head and everything of course it
was not my fault but I couldn't get
people to laugh at it okay and I thought
it was funny like some of these horrible
[ __ ] in my life and my man's like this
[ __ ] ain't funny
[ __ ] you you don't know what it'll be
black in America it's funny to me mm-hmm
and as I look at well I don't I don't
want to give away all your secrets here
miss pett but before we get out of here
you've been so generous with your time
do you have anything else you want the
world to know nobody the book is coming
out and you know check me out on Twitter
I don't do a lot of Instagram but I'm
there
yeah I don't take pictures of my food on
the table this year and I'm also on
Facebook and it's comedian miss Pat MSP
80 just follow me and and when you post
it I'll be more than happy to tweet you
know retweeted absolutely [ __ ] like that
and the book is still gonna be called
rabbit still gonna be Carl rabbit listen
is your childhood nickname and it'll be
pretty interesting
Wow well they may be selling them at the
trunk too hard I would be selling them
at the truck I just think I can do a
better job in the book stop
that's the hustler that Street yes yes
it is
well thank you for your time thank you
for having me